hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and
you're chained in two games but knees
top five where I've carefully cultivated
some of this week's most interesting
stories to get you all up to date on the
gaming stuff microsoft said all of the
things this week and one of those things
with that xbox one and ps4 are both
going to sell loads and that the heat
should all go away yeah I guess I agree
with both those statements Legion Nelson
was the ambassador of peace and love in
the gaming community this week saying
both platforms are off to a great start
the remains of Reddit he is pleaded with
gamers to put down their weapons and
stop prolonging the console war Major
Nelson said Sony will sell a ton we will
sell a ton the industry is going well
and consumers have choice yep all those
statements work for me too are you happy
to see this kind of commentary on the
console war let me know the developer of
candy crush saga King games has been
doing their damnedest to piss everybody
off over the last few weeks and then
attempted to trademark the words candy
and saga as you can imagine this is
seriously shoving a thorn in to the side
of stoic studio is the developer of the
banner saga who've said they will be
fighting the accusation that their
tactical role-playing title is as the
legal document explains confusingly and
deceptively similar to candy crush saga
yes because the banner saga is just full
of came to use puzzle game fans trying
to explode similarly colored blocks and
for what is certainly our biggest story
of the week Microsoft have been pain
cinema partners for positive YouTube
xbox one videos the video creators were
offered a monetary incentive as long as
they didn't mention the partnership
agreement and featured at least 30
seconds of an xbox one game they were
also expected to not be negative about
Microsoft's console its games all the
machinima network mostly this news
divided you guys between being super
disgusted or just unfazed by what
companies will
for good publicity let me know which
side of the debate you find yourself on
in the comments down below the xbox one
went through 75 prototypes before it was
finalized and has been called a
meaningful breakthrough product by
Microsoft Microsoft even 3d printed
prototypes during the process of
deciding between different black shapes
more than 100 designs with drafters at a
connect and over 200 for the Xbox one
controller they also conducted over 40
controller advancements and in a weird
follow-up statistic more than 1,000
pairs of hands tested the controller so
we've talked about GTA 5 being on PC for
a good while now but this week we got
more than just a petition signatures
update a 150 page bug log was leaked
which apparently features over 100 270
references to a pc version of the super
popular game then mentions date back to
jun 2012 and include mentions of DirectX
11 effects and a last gen toggle there
are also notes about PC specific crashes
that requires finding out in addition a
product listing for a pc version of GTA
5 appeared on amazon france but has
since been taken down do you believe GTA
5 is coming to BC and whether or not you
do would you want to play it on the
platform you can let me know in the
comments down below or on my Twitter
where an at Jess McDonald this week on
site Johnny lets you know just how
pleased or displeased you guys were with
the SimCity offline mode announcement I
cover you off on how I think Nintendo
can up their wii u game this year and
seven cam take on Thomas the Tank dragon
in Skyrim mods those are the most of the
things that I cared about this week but
you should let me know what interested
you I'll be back on Monday but till then
I hope you have an excellent weekend